can't be asked to do the whole day in
thing and getting to know someone so
they just tend to settle or sometimes
they settle for the baby daddy that's
given them issues because they have a
child together
um I feel like because women you know
growing up we take such maybe that's why
we sell us more men or women I think
women I think women settle more
because one they might feel like oh okay
I'm getting older I'm lonely
so I'll just settle for any guy and as
well you know we've got a body clock and
you know we want to have kids and things
like that so maybe a thing where okay
I'll just sit with this guy so I can
have kids and just situations like that
where you just feel like oh there's a
lot of times you feel like oh there's no
good men out there so let me just go for
the options
thank you
I think men settle more because I don't
think women in my generation at least
are taught what a woman is supposed to
provide to a man and so they just kind
of expect that because this is what they
want in a man that this is what they're
supposed to be at least that's what I
was told is like be who you want to date
but it's not really true
what do you guys think who settles more
men or women guys
Ricky what that's a really tricky one
this because
um
it's not a matter of settling it's not a
matter of
like December well I'll just go with
this guy you know you you only get to
settle if you have a lot of choice yeah
and that's that's the reason why I would
say that women probably settle more than
men do because men don't have as much
Choice like some considerable margin so
unless of course they are the you know
the alpha you know most men
um no they don't they don't settle they
have one or two opportunities they they
you know they find somebody that
suits them I think you know they don't I
don't think their expectations are as
high so so you know you can call that
settling if you like but I think that
because women have a good deal more
Choice yeah I think it depends what you
mean by settling right so like I think
men settle for what they can get like
most most men because because uh like if
I speak to my friends they they only
have they don't get girls coming to them
all the time right so when they do get a
girl it's like well this is all I've got
so I'm gonna try settle so that's that's
what I think and I think because girls
have more Choice it's it's harder for
them to sorry settle in in today's
today's age if you mean like settle like
as in okay this is what I'm gonna settle
for like I'm gonna settle for this type
of woman or this what like type of thing
because some men only get like that
choice yeah what's the difference
between so what specifically you guys
what is the difference between settling
and that's just your level
so the girl because I you said something
like oh she's just gonna go with her
baby daddy because you know even though
he gives her problems but isn't that
just her level because she can't get
anything better well she could maybe
she's just not looking because she's so
comfortable in her situation or maybe
she could sleep up but not lock him down
but also
um I don't know a lot of with the whole
baby mama baby daddy why is there so
much drama like from it could be from
either side I feel like there's always
something like people don't always break
up in the best amicable way well it's
because they didn't plan a family yeah
exactly did you just get pregnant yeah
it's not really like a decision that
both of them plan but there's also a lot
of women that tried to trap the man as
well which is like he's not gonna love
you just because you have his child you
know well they're paid to do it if you
pay someone to trap people like trap
America she can get child support for 18
years not in the UK it's not worth it
it's like like it's really low and now
it's decent it's like 15 here something
like that if someone's Rich that could
be a decent chunk of change and if
there's a house involved then you get to
live in it until child's 18. oh really
yeah oh I didn't know that
my husband gets thrown out on the street
oh [ __ ] really I didn't actually know
that that's crazy yeah if kids are
involved right yeah yeah
so what is from the ladies what is a guy
that you would settle for
Gandhi
me
um
I feel like if I would settle it would
be more so because of my emotions
um and that would be out of love like if
I genuinely care for that person and you
know sometimes we talk about oh yeah you
know this guy he has so much potential
you know he's going somewhere I feel
like that may be
um a reason for me to settle because of
my emotions oh so it would be like it'd
be like a bum no no you said he's going
somewhere so I'm assuming he's not
somewhere now uh I'm just based off what
you said oh well so you'd be settling
for like a guy that that's not
financially there I'm you're gonna hold
him down
no but I feel as though um the
definition is subjective you know like
personally for me when I say potential I
mean okay someone that is going
somewhere with their their life okay
they have a job or they have a secure
um income but their dreams and
aspirations are a lot larger than what
they have at the moment like for me
personally I would never settle for a
bomb like bummy behavior is no no okay
he's gotta he's gonna have a job I mean
he's got to have like
it needs to be like matching at least
you know you make or higher
a job that he is able to provide for
himself and do things for himself I
don't mean like a bomb that's just
sitting on the couch like oh bye honey
you're welcome home so when you say
saddle so what did you mean when you
said like you're gonna hold him down and
he's gonna no I'm I just necessarily oh
I just meant in terms of like um holding
that person down I don't believe I said
that because no personally
yeah but um no I just mean in in terms
of like supporting that person with
their aspirations I wouldn't hold that
man down like okay that's not how I was
raised okay
what's the guy that you would settle for
that I would sell for yeah
well I got outside of four has to be a
guy that has a good job and good money
um is a family man
um
and yeah
okay so that sounds like a catch
that doesn't sound like saddling
that sounds like give me his number you
know
a man with a job now she said family man
oh yeah okay go ahead I'm with a job who
likes pets
all right good
um I'm not sure if I could settle
because like the number one important
the most important thing for me is
character okay and so kind of an issue
I'm having with dating is like a date
with the intention of marriage and if I
marry then I have to submit and so I
would need somebody in which I trust
their judgment in order to submit to
them so that's like the number one thing
for me and we need to have the same
values which are what
um preferably the same Outlook in terms
of like politics hopefully religion but
it's kind of hard to find
um and somebody that wants a family
mainly
okay I think it's also worth saying that
you know marriage is a partnership very
much a partnership it may be a
partnership you know at the end of the
day if you have two people
um trying to do something they're
they're going to disagree they're they
are absolutely going to disagree so
somebody has to have the casting vote
yeah and
quite often that's the man quite often
it's the woman as well actually but
um you know you need to you need to
build a partnership and practicing
building that partnership in a boyfriend
girlfriend situation is a bloody good
idea not just evaluating them as
somebody who you monitor attach to
yourself but also
but also can I build something together
with this person can I make a
partnership with them you know in the
real sense
you know when you guys are describing
your partners as well is this someone
that you would marry or someone you date
because I feel like because in my
situation right I was I was just a
teacher so like 23k and I was 10K in
debt right so if I told you those two
things I was a teacher 23k and I was in
debt most of you probably wouldn't like
even give me a chance right and this is
why I like kind of your answer a bit
where you said well as long as there's
like drive or like the idea but I think
the problem is you wouldn't even date
that guy in the first place to find out
if you did have a drive or if he did
have that that's that's how that's how
my dad was with my mom like he he was in
a lot of debt when she first met him
like yo I feel like your situation does
not equal your future like no no I agree
I was just saying like yeah like how do
you see that how do you without being
vain or not vain but like selling the
profile you can't you can't get that
right you can't for me